today we're going to tackle the mojito
one of the most popular cocktails in the
world there are a lot of different ways
to make it this is how I like to do it
with a little less soda water and really
letting the min be the star of the show
you only need a handful of ingredients
white rum mint lime soda water and
simple syrup if you don't know how
simple syrup is a cinch to make all it
takes is equal parts sugar and hot water
from the tap
stir it up dissolve it and it keeps in
the fridge for up to a month we're going
to start with an ounce of simple syrup
followed by about eight to ten minutes
and we're gonna muddle those together
when you're muddling remember not to
press too hard you don't want to
pulverize the mint or any herbs you just
want to extract those aromatic oils not
the bitter tannins in the fibers good
now we'll juice some limes remember
fresh juice always put it right into the
[ __ ] here 3/4 of an ounce and finally
2 ounces of white rum when you're
looking for a white rum to buy look for
something with a number on the label it
usually means it's been aged and then
filtered for color but it still retains
some of that rich flavor from the barrel
okay now we're ready to shake
all right strain this into a highball
glass over ice
top it off just a splash little bit of
soda
finally beautiful mint sprig for garnish
so that's how you make a mojito now
you're ready to sit back by the pool put
your feet up and enjoy this classic
Cuban cocktail if you liked this video
and you're looking for more tips to step
up your bartending game subscribe to the
GQ channel if not lots more where that
came from